presenting some challenges on the
three-point line murray quick release on
the three he's got it i mean
what what can you say
that's just a beautiful shot murray
he's got 30 now five made threes murray
little runner is good jamal murray with
an answer
murray goes shot clock at three no
little floater is good
murray three-pointer is up and it's good
you have to credit
you have to credit james harden not many
people in this league have their own
moves we can go through them the hook
shot and they average
nine and a half turnovers when they get
more than nine they lose
denver has been doing it on the
defensive end again in
in the three wins the jazz have had
under
10 turnovers and murray is off the
charts right now
step back three on the way and he's got
another one
man the step back hand in the face
murray here
jokic finding murray murray does he get
another one in him oh you bet he does
and that might be the dagger for another
three
he said last year he did not play the
way that he wanted to play in the
playoffs he wanted to make amends for it
he came out here focused